[Music]  you've all sacrificed so much to be here  and be a part of this thing we're doing  this craze made up of couples the first  ever large-scale colonization mission  and everyone back on earth is really  grateful for hard work  new courage  we're making history here  it was wheat or they ought to find a  human vegetation before America who plan  on it you hear that what nothing  no birds no animals nothing  what happened here  [Music]  [Music]  what's happening tell me about Easter  breaking up  oh it's got a new life  where is it  holy  [Music]  caris be empty  [Music]  [Music]  Hey  [Music]  you sure about this captain how do you  mean  oh yeah what the [ __ ] out there  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]